If you got 19 inches by 10 inches, great work. If you didn't get that answer,
let's see how we got that answer. First, I know that the width of a rectangle is
9 inches less then its length, so we can write the width, w is equal to 9 inches
less then its length. So that's going to be l minus 9. The width is 9 inches
less than its length. We also know that the perimeter is 58 inches. We know the
equation for perimeter is 2 times the length plus 2 times the width, or 2l plus
2w. If we know that w is l minus 9, we can simply replace w in this equation
with what w equals which is l minus 9. And we know that the perimeter is 58
inches. So, I have 2l plus 2 times w, but w equals l minus 9, and that equals
58. Now, I have an equation that I can solve. First, I need to distribute. So, I
have 2l plus 2l. 2 times negative 9 is negative 18 and that equals 58. Now, I
can combine like terms, 2l plus 2l is 4l, add 18 to both sides, so now, I have
4l equals 58 plus 18, which is 76. So, 4l equals 76. Divide both sides by 4, and
I get that l equals 19. So, I have that 4l equals 76, I divide both sides by 4,
which gives me, l equals 19. So, here's one of the dimensions of my rectangle.
19 inches is the length. To get the width, I know the width is equal to the
length minus 9. So, the width is equal to the length, which is 19, minus 9 which
gives me 10. So, the dimensions of the rectangle are 19 inches by 10 inches.
Let's try a ratio problem.